I believe everybody has the opportunity to choose what kind of sex they will
have.
And so it can be sacred,
but then there's times I just want to be a dirty pig and just go out and do
whatever I want.
And that's not saying great.
Three two
film in itself is art,
but art is also subjective.
So for myself,
I do believe that my work is on in some level at creative endeavor,
which actually does reflect the art world.
Okay.
I mean everything that we do is a creative endeavor.
I shoot a lot of features,
which means I shoot a lot of movies that are actually filmed more like
mainstream movies.
It's basically the exact same except in the end we have sex.
Um,
so I said somewhat agree.
I'm still new to the industry,
so I have not really done a lot of feature films.
I had a big productions,
I still do the reality porn where it's like the piece of Guy,
he rings the doorbell and then he fucks the,
the mill for something.
So I don't really see that as art in a way.
As I sat that pizza guy up a certain way.
You have to leave this the doorbell a certain way.
You have to hit the lighting,
your hair lights back there.
Okay.
Three,
two,
one.
Okay.
The type of porn that minors we'll be able to get is most likely going to be
what's free on the Internet and there's a lot of things missing from the clips
that are free on the Internet.
It's not very educational.
It does not teach them the proper way that sex should be done.
Consent Lube,
all of that stuff.
It's missing.
We do a lot of like fantasy roleplay and different things that like maybe you
would want to do but you can't actually do in real life and so if a miner is
watching it,
they don't see what goes on behind the scenes where the partners are like
communicating with each other like you can do this but like this or they don't
ski consent happening on camera.
Porn is a,
it's a fantasy.
It's just not reality.
So a minor watching this is definitely going to get the wrong idea of what real
sex is and how it's done,
how it started off,
how you meet a girl,
you're not going to be the pizza man too many times and it's an open to the
piece and it's Dixon there.
Pause,
sexual harassment folks.
If they were able to watch this,
I think sex would be a lot more numbing and a lot younger age and we don't want
that as a society.
Like we still want sex to still be somewhat sacred to kids.
I'm going to say that I think pornography is a very important part of of
learning and also a minor is somebody who is under 18 so we're talking about 17
1615 they're already probably watching porn or probably dealing with that I
agreed is not the place somebody should learn about sex,
but if they're doing it,
how do we make it so it can be a positive thing
you think they should have like like I don't know,
not softcore but like a boy yarn bite.
That's more education.
Okay.
Oh
I have not shot interracial yet,
no matter what,
they're going to end up making it so that there's a racist title,
like baby goes,
blacked,
blacked on blondes,
big black cock on this little tiny white girl,
something like that.
And I get so much hate on Instagram on Twitter saying I'm racist saying
whatever.
And I'm actually the opposite.
Totally.
I don't want to fucking do that.
There is a whole site,
I mean it's one of the biggest sites in our industry that is black and
interracial.
Interracial.
Interracial is uh,
a white dude.
What a Chinese girl in a interracial is,
anything is interracial.
So for us to just consider the dark age guy with the whitest girl,
I think that's,
it's just so stereotype and then they don't even do that.
They make sure that the guy is gigantically huge or than the other girl.
So it looks intimidating and then I feel like sometimes.
Why else do you think that some people are intimidated by black culture?
It's really bad.
Like I've even gotten companies offering me like hundreds of dollars extra to
shoe interracial.
And it didn't occur to me until like company started dropping off or like I was
getting all these comments being like,
oh my God,
like you need a shoot with more black guys and then we need more PVC and stuff
like that.
People want that.
That's the scary,
that is the more scary part of this conversation.
People actually want racist.
Wow.
Three,
two,
one.
The day they found out,
the first day that my first scene came out,
my mom,
she called me and she was upset and then like a week after that she was like,
you know,
I love you and like,
you're still welcome to come home.
They're not all for a day,
still want me to go back to college.
But they had my back.
I came from a very bad space as a trans guy and like,
you know,
tried to commit suicide,
all kinds of stuff.
So really I think my parents were just really happy on my live.
I'm a hugely successful in the pornography business.
So I think what I did is I taught my parents that this is a business.
It is not just dirty,
nasty porn in the back alley.
All right?
It's actually a real lucrative business if you understand how to create a
business from it.
Most of my family knows what I do and like my parents say approve of it.
They're like,
you do what you want,
you're an adult.
But like my extended family,
my grandparents,
my cousins,
they're all Mormon.
They're super religious.
I've been blocked on social media.
I've been like,
they don't invite me to family reunions anymore just cause they're like,
you can do what you want but because our religion views it this way,
we're not comfortable with you being like around our kids and stuff like that.
Yeah.
What makes it sad is like it does make you feel like people forget the person
that you are.
Like it's just a job.
Like this is just a job for me.
Three,
two,
one.
I have my husband,
we are open and we're in a poly relationship and I'm learning that,
you know,
you get what you want.
And so if you're not cool with what I do,
then you don't get to talk to me.
I don't,
I struggle is,
um,
the monogamous part because if you're with me,
we have to be open because I'm going to be out with other people a lot.
And I was married and it got,
we ended it because he wanted to be monogamous and he couldn't handle seeing me
go out with other people.
And it's like,
it gets to a point with people where they're like,
okay,
do we want to be monogamous or are we going to be open?
Can I even handle being open?
Like,
you know,
I was engaged to somebody in the industry and you know,
it's not easy to find a person that you have a real connection with innocent
history.
You know,
sometimes porn can destroy,
you know,
relationships and can destroy people.
You know,
cause
I don't have her anymore.
And honestly,
I don't know if I ever will.
You know,
because sometimes what it does and people immensely can scar you.
I didn't want to accept it for what it was.
I didn't want to think that porn was really hurting.
My relationship were really hurting her as much as it was at times.
He just,
nothing you can do when you just,
like I say,
you live and you learn.
There's a lot of things that happen that people don't understand when we go to
work.
We are disconnected from intimacy.
Yeah.
They people don't know how to do that in their own lives so they don't believe.
I think a lot of times they don't believe us because a lot of times
tell me what you think.
It's just normal sex.
I'm like,
Yo,
I'm angled like this.
I am backwards.
I'm like making sure the light's getting inside of here so you guys can see
what's going on.
Like I'm not on top of this girl.
How you here and kissing her and making love to her like that's what I would do
at home.
It is a completely a job.
We are disconnected.
It is you're,
you're doing all of this as a motion and as an actor you're an actor
three,
two,
one.
So I uh,
personally I think it's a very personal choice.
I believe everybody has the opportunity to choose what kind of sex they will
have,
how they want to have sex,
when they want to have sex,
why they want to have sex.
And so it can be sacred in a situation where I might want feel like I have a
lover and I want to keep it very personal and I don't want to,
but then there's times I just want to be a dirty pig and just go out and do
whatever I want.
And that's not sacred.
Like there's relationships,
sex that you actually feel for the person and stuff.
And then there's genital sex where you just want to fucking get off.
Right.
When I was 18 I those couple of years from 18 to 21 in the industry,
I was a mess.
I didn't know how to separate my personal life from my porn life.
I can't be eight and actually 24 seven and when I first got in the industry,
I thought that that's who I was.
I was ordering my Starbucks coffee and telling them I was Aiden.
Okay.
And that's how I knew that,
like I needed to come back and still have my real self and then be able to turn
into eight.
And when I go to set,
I would like some business cards.
Instagrams knew as soon as everything,
like I'm easy to find me.
I'm on every,
yeah.
Hey guys,
my name is Michael.
Thanks so much for watching this episode.
If you like what you saw,
subscribe and let us know what you thought in the comments.
See it.